[Music]
this is it's an old friend episode of
rogue theory that I'm excited about but
first just looking at what we'll be
talking about the directors of the
biggest movie of all time you may have
heard a bit of Enders endgame they drop
some bombshells in to Reddit last night
and we're gonna dive real deep into some
of those and blow it up with our rogue
theories but with us this time you know
old friends are going through obviously
Erik Bosse is an old alright I'm still
here I don't you don't get to leave but
Brandon Barrack he we've known Brandon
for well I've known I met you 15 years
ago yeah guys we were both negative to a
comedian and all sorts of other things
but but real quick also I just want to
admit that I also I met you basically at
a heroes and villains party that you
threw oh yeah my birthday party here
yeah I'm villains part and like 12 years
after that I stole that idea and I made
it my birthday it was the first one to
ever think of that
sure so you are everywhere on the
internet right now yeah so instead of
putting anyone at anything specific just
like hit this girl up on Twitter and
we'll talk more about we can find people
later yeah just hit her up on Twitter
the quick reminder that you used to is
that this show can be found as a podcast
it's way earlier than the video version
subscribe to that wherever you get your
podcast but yeah so we're saying on this
episode we got some road theories about
some endgame stuff whatever we're also
gonna hit a spider-man World News the
world Survivorman and Suicide Squad yeah
the guys all right so the Russo brothers
did this reddit AMA all right and they
were asked couple questions I just want
to like go directly some of these
questions their answers and then discuss
some theories with you guys
so first of all someone asked what else
they're working on okay and regarding
possibly other franchises and they said
we are quietly and secretly which I
don't think they need to say both those
words working on a franchise right now
all right
separately somewhere else they said that
it is a it'd be a big surprise to people
to find out that they'd be working on
this so first of all yeah what do we
think it is in fact let's say just it
could be within Marvel so let's stay
there for a second what do we think well
what do we know about what they are
doing for sure they're doing this 21
bridges movie that's coming out soon
they have this was it a D&D or Magic the
Gathering series that they're doing they
have this like spy series for Amazon but
like a surprising franchise within the
MCU yeah within the MCU they've talked
about wanting to do a Secret Wars movie
that's something that like other than
the Infinity Gauntlet saga they would
love to do Secret Wars they said they're
secretly working it's a franchise now do
they mean like a franchise film or do
they mean like they're starting their
own sub franchise within the MCU like
maybe the x-men or something like that
like there are the mutants
yeah the new version of the mutants and
there we are but we're finally gonna do
x-men right I think I think x-men have
been very hot and cold and I would like
to see a start to finish
really nice x-men run where there wasn't
like a lukewarm in between yeah we feel
confident for a movie the movie like
it's so weird with x-men like they just
they're always like would even like Dark
Phoenix they're always like teasing it
and then they do it and every time they
do it they do it so wrong but because
they bring back literally the exact same
person that wrote the previous draft of
a version that everyone loved by but
loved to hate and then they just got the
same team and they did the exactly
again what I would love if they are
doing x-man is I do think that the Russo
brothers with their take on on civil war
with their take on Winter Soldier all
these things they find these these other
ways to tell stories they ground them
except for infinity wearing on game you
shouldn't really ground those stories so
much although they're the it was them
that decided we need to give make Thanos
the the center of that movie and give
him the arc which is a version of
grounding it right instead of like
spaceman just wants to impress mr. Steph
but so if they did that with the x-men
maybe we would finally see you know new
like we don't have to see the flashback
to Jean Grey's house you know when she's
growing up or maybe they tried to do
that a little bit with trying to bring
mystique in and like look we're telling
one thing slightly differently but yeah
I'd be very excited they're doing that
okay not x-men what about Fantastic Four
maybe I mean that's like another cursed
franchise you know the fan of the trick
you know it was an interesting approach
I don't a stick for yeah I know I think
you're gonna do Fantastic Four I mean
the big question is now in this MCU if
you're introducing these other heroes
like mutants or like the Fantastic Four
like where have they been the whole time
are they from another dimension you know
I think now that they've opened up that
like kind of dimension hot pot that's a
multiverse yeah that's right here you
know your God from the Machine for
everything right like everything can be
solved with like oh they're just from
another you know okay I kind of love the
whole multiverse aspect of comics I like
that it's convenient to just be like
that's another one yeah it's another
plain big yes your yes your mom was
killed in front of you in this universe
but this version in front of you what
the movies are different yeah because we
get so many different stories around
characters we love that's why I'm on
board with I don't like you know it you
want to change some stuff and just say
it's a different but it's a different
you know plane of existence I'm okay but
I know but my my pitch for the where to
take Batman
post the where it's at now which I feel
like a lot of us are still like yeah the
Christopher Nolan films like know we've
had Batman films since then my pitch is
go ahead and do alternate reality
Batman's you know let's do a new are
Batman
you know let's set them different times
it's had frickin Dark Knight
returned to Sunday bike and insane - a
true gear one story it really did not
just do all of these different versions
of them because I think that character
can withstand it - but do we think you I
mean would it be for that I mean I guess
people might say that's surprising for
them I would say like that's right on
brand for the Russos to tell another
like team story with like quirky
slightly broken people who save the
world in some way like if anything I
would say not the Fantastic Four and
maybe not even Secret Invasion cuz
that's another like government
conspiracy story for them I think if if
we're talking about like what's
off-brand for ruses what's surprising
for them within the MCU were like cosmic
multiverse interdimensional or like some
other like alternate plan an alternate
reality thing that we haven't met yet
maybe a Silver Surfer Galactus story
something like that and we know we can
go there because just from the little we
know about Wanda vision and the next
Doctor Strange movie like multiverse is
here we are firmly in it that Pandora's
box has been open so I like that our
question was is the multiverse real
because of you know Mysterio might was
apparently lying about everything and
he's the one that's like by the way I'm
from the multiverse and he's just a liar
and he worked down the street in New
York but now they're like oh no let's
just put in the title that question
we're there yeah well maybe they're
working on something that's like a much
smaller comic that's in the frame like
that Marvel owns four years or something
that people forgot about you know or
maybe they're like secretly doing like
Richie Rich or something let's go out of
MCU like what are just some franchises
I'm gonna throw out there because I I've
heard this was like a real thing that
almost was happening a while back just
the hasbro toys and the hat like that
whole Hasbro universe battleship was
supposed to be the beginning of like the
Hasbro universe so I'll just throw out
there okay fine
they already do it so nevermind I
changed it to the cereal box characters
Count Chocula not him complicated with
the right sony has Count Chocula
captain crunch Chocula but he can't eat
chocolate maybe Mighty Max says Mighty
Max years ago is like just that needs to
come back in general you guys murmur
mighty max yes I don't weirdly gory yeah
I totally knew the cartoon of it is
amazing by the way cartoon has one of
the best I know once no one's watching
the any of this now subtle might spoil
in it but spoiler would for mighty max
watching the whole series they he's he
puts on his head and it takes to
transport him to this like separate side
University just a kid he deals with a
foul or something or whatever it is a
Birdman wise Birdman and they try to
like to feed things over and at the end
of the whole thing they lose they don't
defeat him and the whole story starts
all over again but this is after like
years whatever I'm saying infinity war
we are long overdue for a rooster
brothers Applegate Christina Applegate
what am i say not gonna say it k
Applegate Animorphs reboot like
surprising and it's gonna be it's gonna
make a billion dollars start keeping a
count of the number of times
eric has brought up Animorphs unprompted
looking at the elements tomb only I can
see these pods time out there I'm I
clamor for this every single time I get
to talk about a comic book series that
needs to be seen on screen and housing
it but lock and key please and I think I
reserve others lock and key would be
very interesting things that I really
love about logging key is that it's so
dark and disturbing so I yeah I'd be
interested to see you Russa brothers
take on lock and key now that being said
if at anytime that anyone's listening to
this there probably is some type of lock
and key project in the works room or
whatever but every time that's happened
so far it hasn't actually made it
anywhere that people could watch besides
one panel at comic-con years ago and
then never be
that so I'm not considering it a thing
until I can see it with my eyeballs
that's what I was just thinking about it
for saga because I was like saga is
Marvel right as in like the MCU in that
it is written exactly like the current
MCU films are works like funny but so
sad at times and intense and great
action so they do saga that'd be a
perfect fit for them it's just I can't
remember if that is already in the works
somewhere I mean I'm sure it's like like
why the last man or something we're
never come to fruition I want to see I
need someone to finally finish the story
a novel was ever a comic for the cartoon
Pirates of Dark Water it was catch all
these jewels to start with the dark
water remember that from spreading and
he got half of them hmm
push the dark water back a little bit
but never finished his journey we stupid
me as a kid I didn't know what pirates
were I've to fur like like way too long
I was like 11 somebody didn't really
come up in Miami growing up like pirates
was not it wasn't a thing that it's it's
it's so weird I had learned this later
and there's people from Miami right now
in the comments like what are you
talking about that was too real
maybe it's like like a ocean threat from
the ocean pirates were no nerve Miami or
the mayor of Miami was a pirate but I
was like too old so what that cartoon
came on I was like I can't relate to
this these people watch swords on a boat
like Miami the lego pirates or the
muppet pirates you're just like what is
this Peter power also English was not my
first language and so when I would hear
these like very new words I was just not
like yeah right and I think there was a
time where I thought pirates and
Panthers were the same thing
let's get Blackbeard in Black Panthers
totally across she was years ago
I only get it kind of mixed up these
options of franchises they could take
with the best but also throw out there
we could be like Quiznos or Subway
franchises but yeah what are we thinking
what do we actually want their energy
now that I said it I actually am in a
boat for saga I think that would be
amazing huh well I I said locking key
only because they said people would be
surprised to find out they were working
on it so maybe not something that fits
as well as a saga although I would love
to see a Russo brother saga I'm with you
I mean I hope they do do Fantastic Four
cuz I feel like those guys really need a
good movie they need a win they need
they need a win they need a W daredevil
got his W do you remember but I mean
after the last Fantastic Four movie then
the comic died yeah well because how bad
it was Marvel wasn't gonna make comics
that we couldn't control the movies they
be killed off the x-men they kill out
the Fantastic Four and that's so petty
by the way like they killed characters
that were like starting and you can say
it's petty but it's petty
it's padding outfox to make terrible
movies just to not lose the right
specially and describe what you mean
they're like how legally they're did
that yeah yeah cuz like if they didn't
make with daredevil they just gave up
they're like we can't make a good
daredevil movie we we give but they were
so sure that like Oh Fantastic Four is
gonna be worth day and so they kept they
made an original movie with Roger Corman
that never even got released just to
hold on to the rights and they may be
making the movie gives them like another
buff so like they were gonna lose it
again after that second terrible
Fantastic Four movie with nip/tuck was
not the problem he did a great job
yeah I actually liked the idea of like
Galactus being a storm rather than like
earlier we were trying to talk about
like are we talking about Galactus this
episode not really okay then we can talk
about it real quick sidebar going rogue
I just as Eric was about to give this
good Galactus is potential
the threat that we're all like well
where do you go after danos you go to
Galactus first of all I don't know that
you need to go back into space you could
do a nip-tuck you could do Doctor Doom
or something but if we do do Galactus he
is such a weird concept and they did ego
kind of weird when they they're like he
is a planet for a second if you blur
your eyes but doing Galactus he's a
space giant that is larger than planets
I was talking to you guys about this
earlier he doesn't actually go like eat
a planet like that he like absorbs it so
he doesn't need to be a giant for any
reason he just needs to be some sort of
energy stuck resources so what you said
I agree with yeah yeah you know they've
played around with that a little in
Marvel you know the the Mandarin fake
out and things like that I think it
would be weird to do Galactus as like a
giant dude though that being said I
remember 10 years ago I was like well
they'll never do the guardians of the
galaxy because we can't have like I have
a talking raccoon and a big tree in a
movie like but it's great I cried a lot
it of digital raccoon we don't know what
he is I cry every time pretty much I see
baby Groot on screen you know when he's
in danger I'm like it hits me in like a
weird yeah I have a two-year-old yeah at
home so well it started at two I have a
two-year-old at home it his first
cosplay was baby Groot okay but the
reason I bring that up is did that
create now suddenly a wave of emotions
associated yeah I watch movies
completely differently now it's
terrifying and I play video games
completely different interesting like
what games any games that deal with kids
at all like if kids are in danger at all
it's almost like I have to take a time
out and step away fly kid in Walking
Dead The Walking Dead game playing games
before that emotional like I guess
emotional stakes where risen is the best
way to say but playing
games before that it was like man
they're doing stuff to kids those people
are awful and now it's like the whole
world around me is ending and like I
stream on Twitch and I'll be like I'm
sorry guys I'm gonna take a breather and
be right back and I'll put up a BRB
screen and like have to take a 10-minute
otally differently now but yes with
movies like oh yeah baby Groot I'm like
to watch like Spielberg movies are in
the Amblin ones like the classic
structure is to put children in danger
and disrupt the whole unit and now like
as a kid you're like oh yeah kids like
me in danger that's fun that's an adult
like your empathy drives start to kick
any of you you know I feel that will and
stranger things cuz the rest of them
clearly I like are they smoke cigarettes
or something like this like to like like
be cool but whatever Will's are gonna
scene with them I'm like oh god this
poor kids like I'm in Hollywood I'm even
like please keep him away from drugs
don't you see her baby in front of a
railroad track and that's what it feels
like you feel like you want to jump into
the movie and get that kid out of danger
and then just like nurse um well the
Russos talked about that Mary MA they
mentioned how like you know this having
spoiler alert Tony died you know make
the choice to know which Tony which Tony
with Tony like sacrifice his life
knowing he was you know leave his wife
and his child fatherless that was a
heavy thing cuz they understood that as
parents you know it's tough choice we
all cried like big children in the
theatre oh yeah two perspectives on that
so they're they're creating something
that resonates with fathers and you know
or mothers or whatnot but like he's
going to leave his family behind that's
the motivation for Breaking Bad right
like he does everything he does Sam he's
sick and he's going to leave his family
behind and they're gonna be broke but
from the same story can work the other
direction that's why as kids we were
also traumatized by Lion King it's the
same thing the father's dying but it's
not it's not about like he's leaving us
without food and money it's just like my
protectors gone well and that's why you
can understand like baron zemo's
motivation of being so upset because his
family's killed by these these jerks
flying around shooting off pulsar rays a
little revenge he's angry
I'm team Z MODOK your baby - a lizard
the baby makes a choice because he
touches the cube they have a cube in
that universe - if they old enough to
make the choice yeah I'm not gonna get
into that argument is this a dead
franchise do they still write new
Animorph books well I believe the series
is done but there is a thriving fan
fiction community so next question that
I wanted going to from the BA MA they
specifically addressed which character
from the MCU would you want to create a
film about and they're like yeah
Wolverine done so what is their version
of Wolverine look like well I think Hugh
Jackman was one of the you good things
about the new green like about that
series of movies Logan I think was just
like perfection if you think like any
filmmaker James Mangold already told
that story with Logan so they're
probably not gonna tell it that I would
say like maybe I was 23 like X 23 has
been great Logan's story has not only
been told so well and finalized so well
but Hugh Jackman playing Wolverine is
another Robert Downey jr. as Tony Stark
like it's like that person is now so in
everyone's mind as that character that
it would be really hard I mean if you
did something close it would be very
uncanny valley and if you did something
completely 180 people would probably
reject it at least at first so yeah I
think going with an x 23 would be really
cool yeah or like his son or something
you know if they pull in like he's like
someone made a secret Wolverine which
they kind of did have done that yeah I
mean Logan was great I think it kind of
it made us see the whole Logan story a
lot better like I think early on there
was a lot of problems with Wolverine but
I'm also like I think moving such an
easy answer for them like there's
someone I think it's them like I don't
know if they're they're putting their
chips on the table with or something
kind of right because like anybody who
is probably saying like yeah
The Wolverine people right I think they
have the keys to the castle this point
they made the most profitable film of
all time and I think like them saying
it's gonna be surprising it's Disney
like they they're the people who put JJ
Abrams in charge of Star Wars like how
big of a surprise is that like I think
they're just gonna give them like hey
you guys are in charge of x-men now like
they're gonna play it safe and give
these guys who proven they can build a
franchise and sustain it and the key
says something that people want to see
thriving and rebooted so so I'll take
your answer as x-23 or Wolverine jr. as
like a way that they could bring
Wolverine in it sounds like maybe a solo
film or side character that is like the
mantle at least of Wolverine that's
rogue theory a what about though they're
gonna find a way to bring in just
specifically Wolverine I'm wondering
what their version of that looks like
just to him no x-men no other mutants
maybe I mean I am thrown out there the
possibility of maybe not right I mean
it's tough like they they really I think
they thrive on like these kind of genre
style movies you know like the way those
soldiers like the spy story so what's
the Wolverine genre maybe they go 180
and do like a comedy like a Wolverine
comedy well so maybe they do buddy cop
or something Deadpool or something like
you think what is relationship well
brain has so many like fun relationships
great role in the in the comics with
with spider-man like we know maybe
people want to do what was the the
Canadian force the Canadian Avenger
alpha flight maybe they won't do the
Alpha fights or with sasquatch
yeah they easily could that's something
they could do is start way before his
x-men style right yeah like Wolverines
memories Swiss cheese right so you can
the problem and yeah use too much you
guys Swiss cheese brain
cool do any thoughts on on like I guess
it's I'm trying to identify Russo
brothers what did they do specifically
to the characters that we knew because
they did so here maybe this also explain
what I mean
Joss Whedon's take on the Avengers is
not the same thing as the Russo brothers
take and I think actually Joss Whedon's
take is a little bit more Firefly and
Buffy kind of energy of work with while
we fight which is very fun and was
interesting but also didn't work in an
age of Ultron and then the Russo
brothers did kind of be like we died
like we're we're sad you know where we
grow out our roots community like they
took the lessons from community this mix
of like you know so Danny but like
heartfelt tragedy at moments yeah I mean
there's some pretty quickly
yeah but so that's interesting so then
if it is so community is famously
structured on on hero's journey but I
they they structure the episodes of
community untraditionally first sitcom
it's cold open 3x and tag and sitcoms
are usually two acts or done differently
but basically they were like no we want
to hit the drama beats in our comedies
so they did kind of do that with with
Captain America definitely they made
that a pretty serious character
especially on looking at First Avenger
yeah where you go from one to two it's a
big jump and that's when I think
everyone was like okay we're gonna be
okay with all these movies now but yeah
we were worried after cuz I didn't
really enjoy the first Captain America
movie yeah I liked the first doorway
more than the first Captain America was
so different I was like at least this is
a little different so then going by this
logic there Wolverine would be I mean
Wolverines already dark if we go Logan
Logan's already really well but he
wasn't dark in his introduction on the
Fox explains well and that's so what I
was gonna answer to your question is
maybe go back and do justice to Logan's
origin story and maybe back it up before
he actually becomes Wolverine so you
mean he's just someone who can deal and
then the x-23 project is ahead of him
sure and he was like you said you know
his memory Weapon X sorry yeah we see
his uh you know when we look at his
background we're seeing it through his
eyes and like you said he s with cheese
brain so
there's a lot I'm a picker so it might
it might be nice for us as the audience
to see even though he's not telling us
from his own experience I'd have to kind
of tell a different story than what we
saw in x-men origins because they did
they start with he's a kid during Civil
War era a pretty Civil War era he takes
on the name James Howell and you kind of
see that bit of an origin but like
people don't really go crazy for that
story so if you want to reboot something
that Wolverine those kind of free this
is somewhere that's interesting instead
of doing that I mean you can do
Wolverines is from the 1800s and his
mutant abilities you know made it so he
ages very slowly but if we are
potentially doing something where
Scarlet Witch is suddenly about to
create a bunch of mutants and it's about
to be a brand new thing I don't think
anyone is like what's essential and
corridor Wolverine is that he's from the
1800s he's racist he talks old-timey
like these aren't essential core parts
of them right it could just be he's he's
kind of old and group and clearly seen
some [ __ ] so maybe it's like he's
activated and he's just like a soldier
away at war or something and he gets
like you know shot by a sniper or
something and and his whole unit does
and then he just like gets back up and
he's like what's going on and then we we
see the beginning of a healed healing
Wolverine it's not he wasn't born that
way it's they're all created in a moment
yeah having a Wolverine that's like born
in like modern-day you know somebody
thought yeah yeah it also will help the
aging problem of like we start with
someone really young because they said
they wanted to go young right yeah and
then they just don't what feels like
they're setting up all these young new
body driven Avengers I'm in a pretty
body driven that's true that's true but
now it'll be even more body driven all
right the last like major question I
want to touch on here that came from the
AMA is of course a freakin said this is
gonna drive Eric crazy they said that
there's another big easter egg that has
not been found in an gay
yet we can guess like what kind of thing
it could be but my real question is are
they lying I mean it could be they're
just waiting for someone to say I found
this thing and they're like yep that was
it you nailed it buddy what was the
James gun story we still don't know he
he said that like people have partially
found it but not the whole thing like
the James Gunn said there was one more
missing Easter egg in the first
guardians of the galaxy right so people
online and various reddit threads do
tubers other than us who have really
started to crack the code but literally
it's a code so you see the coordinates
under each planet like oh now they're at
Zander there's coordinates so people
have kind of decoded it using some kind
of alpha numeric key that has decoded
this and like this is Meredith quill ego
mom's cancer are words that have shown
up but it's not consistent sometimes you
have to like turn letters sideways and
now it looks like an e you know it's not
it's not like ooh it's broken we figured
out the code it's like people kind of
saying maybe this and I don't know if
people will ever find it it wouldn't
surprise me at all James Gunn it's just
like yeah it's out there keep rewatching
my movie I'll keep saying relevant the
view it's only on streaming okay make
sure you buy the blu-ray so you have it
at home so you watch it over and over no
yeah and you should probably buy a new
blu-ray each time and just in case I put
it in later yeah I mean if you look at
something like in-game sure I mean we
are in the process of rewatching it we
do find new things but like a lot of
times it's like oh you remember that
Memorial in San Francisco or Scott Lynx
are literally thousands of names one of
them is just the art directors son's
name and that's the Easter Egg like is
that you know what do we define as
Easter Egg just something that they
consider to be a fun little wink or what
John Watts actually said there is a
Howard the Duck Easter Egg hidden on one
license plates and it's kind of a fun
thing because it reference like a sub
cover page that takes place on the
Staten Island Ferry where that scene
takes place that to me is it true Easter
Egg but sometimes it's just like oh it's
it's you know my kid's birthday is a
number on a license plate like is that
who cares yeah you think you've been
burned yeah I just content to do so see
I saw people theorizing online that gwen
stacy may have appeared
[Music]
yeah this is really this cuz it's like
there's a girl passes by Peter Parker
and Ned when they have their reunion
moment she's wearing a spider web
pattern skirt it has blonde hair pink
backpack let's go in Stacy you can find
that skirt on Hot Topic just like wear
it it what surprised me at off that
extra showed up that day videos wearing
also the girl trips in her neck snaps
the Cameron says I'm Spyder quick maybe
the actress did this maybe they just
haven't liked the real thing here is
Sony's gonna have to charge Marvel a lot
of money to feature gwen stacy in their
movie cuz orful doesn't own gwen stacy
so as Marvel gonna shell it all that
money just for an extra to pacify you
know kind of a fun like post credit
scene they're gonna work in Gwen's days
you know so speaking of spider-man and
these side characters and what Marvel
can do and what Sony can do we're about
to get to a big announcement that just
came out very recently from some of our
favorite filmmakers but first people
help us make the show me and ease
doesn't take themselves too seriously
and they think we shouldn't take undies
too seriously either they believe undies
should be soft fit you perfectly offer
some fun patterns and give you the
freedom to express yourself and they
don't just have undies they got super
comfy onesies and loungewear perfect for
sitting on that couch and slowly rocking
back and forth after seeing that new it
chapter 2 trailer all creepy-like I
actually legitimately wear exclusively
me IDs now because they're so freakin
soft under my pants I'm obsessed with
them I really love the high tech fabric
that me on diseases it's micro modal
it's three times softer than cotton so
it's really comfortable to wear it's
also really durable I can wear when I
exercise to get your 15% off your first
pair free shipping and a hundred percent
satisfaction guarantee you go to me
undies comm slash rockstars that's me on
DS comm slash rock stars for 15% off
your first payer and free shipping you
spend one third of your life asleep so
you should be comfortable Casper
mattresses can help Casper's products
are designed to mimic human curves
providing supportive comfort for all
kinds of bodies the original Casper
mattress combines multiple supportive
memory foams for a quality sleep surface
with
the right amount of sink and bounce
breathable design also helps you sleep
cool and regulates your body temperature
throughout the night the mattress is
delivered right to your door in a
surprisingly small box you'll be a
little freaked out at how small of a box
a full size super comfortable mattress
can be shipped in actually legitimately
got one of these for my mom and she says
it's her favorite mattress she's ever
had in her entire life that's for real
by the way you can be sure of your
purchase with Casper's 100 night
risk-free sleep on it trial and you
could get $100 towards select mattresses
by visiting Casper comm slash rock stars
and using rock stars at checkout and of
course terms and conditions apply that's
Casper comp / rock stars and promo code
rock stars for $100 towards select
mattresses all right back to it guys
were back I was just talking about you
think you can say yeah that's fine I was
just talking about where we're
potentially headed with spider-man
that's better you could did you guys see
this news about Lord and Miller they're
using the spider verse to live-action on
TV well so they there's like no details
on this yet so we're super just
speculative here but yeah they are
saying that they are potentially doing
multiple live-action series with
spider-man characters with Sony TV and
Sony TV is reminding us they have the
according them hundreds of characters
that they had the exclusive rights to so
are there those characters that were
like hell yeah they have blank blank and
blank and we're super excited to see
them well there's like all the weird
symbiote characters the venom films are
going yeah right right the scream Lasher
agony phase yeah those other five one
even lady to lady venom is part of it so
if all the venom version yeah but then
you also have like these other spiders
you have like once we've seen I'd love
to see you live-action spider-ham just
get a pig yeah pretty so we already
hinted at animated versions of the other
spider things so you've spider Gwyn
you know Mouse morality there's all the
other people who have donned like this
later man mantle my let's follow that
they're at a Miles Morales live-action
show if they can't do a movie right
because I mean it feels like they can to
do a live-action version of that could
they do it as a show would we want to do
to the show might be done for an
animated version yeah but still
live-action I would like to see it as a
live-action show I think a lot of people
have been clamoring to see Miles Morales
on screen for a long time and for
whatever reason it hasn't been done yet
so let's make it happen in a live-action
show especially just kind of taking it
back for a hot second to the Marvel
conversation we were just having earlier
knowing that phase four of the MCU is
going to really tie in television with
film why not let's do it let's get Miles
Morales maybe starting a TV show and
then somewhere later on down the line on
the big screen yeah what kind of Sony
could force disney marvel's hand by
having such a popular live-action
version of the character that they have
to make another deal with them to get
them in their movies and their Disney
Plus streaming shows because right now
I'm sure there's some people at Disney
Marvel were like the Sony's doing pretty
well with their Jumanji movies in their
spider-man movies and we kind of want
them to fail enough so we can just like
buy them the way we did you know Myles
and Peter and all these things under our
umbrella you still have a lot of the
villains by the way like most of those
villains are individual deals but they
have Elektra I think they have Green
Goblin I'm not sure we're basically so I
mean a sinister six TV show sounds a
little bit of like lower than I'd
imagined you know it's scale like
meeting like it'll never happen no I
kind of mean like they've got to go with
films for that I'd imagine you could do
like the comic reboot of sinister sticks
a few years ago was great had a very
funny tone and that would make like a
great animated show I think like doing
kind of like yeah they're talking live
at any get big live-action unfortunately
it's probably gonna mean lower budget
rather than or smaller ideas more
grounded like we've explored the idea of
a damage control thing like there's at
NBC oh yeah trying to be the idea of
damage control and we saw that a bit and
far from home like you want to do like a
work
kind of thing another like agents of
shield type show that Sony wants to have
that's one way you could do it well it
doesn't miles
he's like theorized to already exist in
the MCU be a dog lovers night is so it's
like he's already kind of there I mean
he might show up in like what if maybe I
don't know I'd be down to see some
villain origin stories I mean and and I
wouldn't I wouldn't err on the side of
you know just because it's a TV show
it's got lower budget and that means
it's not gonna be as awesome because I
feel like this was the best yeah
portrayal and we've seen and that was a
television show so I'm uh I'm on board
yeah like what if there's just a show
called Harry Osborn it's just like
because we haven't seen Oscorp
father-son I mean in the the ps4
spider-man game there was a whole thing
with Harry I like Harry Osborn it's like
spoiler word if you haven't played the
big game where he becomes venom like
where Norman Osborn's trying to
experiment with this son and he's kind
of turned him into venom you see the
venom strand at the end but maybe
there's something there that you can do
a live action where you have like a
father-son show kind of like you know in
Smallville you had like Lex and Lionel
Luthor and like there was like some
father-son drama there and Lex is he
trying to be like like his corporate
father or maybe there's something there
with arias born I don't know if I'd
watch it but hey some people ain't yeah
they said lots of characters which is
the only reason why I feel like okay
they're dipping into villains yeah for
sure that's it that's interesting I'm
also thinking about specifically them
right Lord and Miller what what seems
like it's up their alley so let's remind
people stuff that Lord and Miller did
they I remember them back from Clone
High and Clone High was like the first
thing I saw there's the lego movie
anyone jump straight to Jump Street you
know and solo but that's why I think
they would love like the sinister six
cuz they're a little silly and you know
I think there's a lot comedy and in
those characters cuz they're so weird
it's almost like the Batman villains
were there they're so focused on like
one thing like I do this one thing it's
my bad thing right I make things go fast
they did that a lot with a little lego
movie right like just focused on how
silly it is to be obsessed also I mean
their take on well they inspired that
take of Batman but then Chris
what's-his-face is the guy
really ran with it but the Lego Batman
story is that obsessive I'm an obsessive
billionaire that wears a bat suit so
that means I'm insane right but if that
comes from gram so yeah that's really
interesting like going that villain
route but then also just playing it like
as a game or maybe like other heroes cuz
like there's like black cat you know
some of like spider-man's friends that
we haven't seen show up yeah animated
show my friends yeah all right so we're
excited because that first one we
brought it up is a little bit like do
they have the characters to support
their own stuff that is not gonna
include spider-man it can include Aunt
May I don't it might not be able to
include kingpin that's why I'm not sure
yeah cuz kingpin was in the kingpin in
there yeah they kind of referenced him
as the kingpin but really they called
him Wilson Fisk that was his name into
the spider I don't really like to say
the names in the MCU as much but it's
this weird like side corner of the MCU
that's not like real MCU it's just kind
of connected but not really so like
there's all these things in there where
I don't it's not truly like there's
references to I don't think they even
mentioned shield in that world do they
like there's no no that's interested
well but those characters are so I know
shield is somehow supposed to be like
beneath the radar a little bit so maybe
they just don't know it exists and they
also don't know that like knew or
Washington DC was attacked after the
Battle of New York no one ever mentioned
sokovia you know there's there's very
few references to other big events other
than the Battle of New York in these
Marvel Netflix show the New Yorkers I
mean there's no world outside I don't
walk around like talking about all the
great tragedies that have happened at
all times if you were so obsessed with
defending your city and something
catastrophic happened in your city and
you're a super you probably would talk
about it it's a fair point the details
of that I feel like we just we have to
wait and see cuz we're so early on they
literally just said hey we're doing a
thing we think about a lot of people
maybe yes Oni okay so yeah who knows
we'll stay tuned to that instead a thing
that we know is happening is James
Gunn's Suicide Squad sequel alright and
he just threw out there hey by the way
the name of this is not suicide
- or to a side squad or anything like
that it's the Suicide Squad and I feel
like that actually has implications for
what that might mean like why would he
just take Suicide Squad it and be like
no this is the Suicide Squad what do we
think what our theories on what he's
trying to communicate about what his
films gonna be well isn't there like an
implicit reboot there by saying thus in
the way that like the Batman and Matt
Reeves news story is gonna be like a
reboot like it's almost as if like we're
pretending that the most recent version
of this did not happen and we're
starting fresh so when he says like the
Suicide Squad it's it's almost it seems
like a bit too soon like why not just
have like another spin-off name from it
the way that we have like Captain
America the Winter Soldier or Thor
probably margot robbie because not only
was she good but like birds of prey
things so it'd be weird for them to
reboot Suicide Squad and not have margot
robbie illegally well we still don't
have confirmed exactly who it sounds
like Will Smith will not be in it right
it is not a lot of them won't be I mean
fair call yeah so I mean that could be
the part that that it's trying to to
communicate is you know we could talk a
lot about Mantle's lately maybe the
mantle of the Suicide Squad it's like
making the varsity team or something
well that's not a great team to be put
on a suicide team suicide but it does
have that rotating cast vibe to maybe
he's trying to like underline yes these
films are going to have people die that
are on the team and we'll just switch
them out and keep making these movies
maybe they want to keep it meta like
that by saying these Suicide Squad the
beginning will be like well the first
iteration of Suicide Squad didn't work
yeah some of you guys in to replace the
other guys that didn't test well it's
just so weird because that movies still
made a ton of money won an Oscar right I
wanted Oscar for like makeup in hair
[Music]
aesthetics so I died for sure but that
much makeup all over again
like people like a lot of domestic
audiences weren't were mixed on this
movie overseas people liked it people
like Will Smith movies so it's weird for
them to like imply that the last one was
like a Josh Trank fan for stick style
failure it wasn't it wasn't
especially for my finances it's one of
those films that has the it's the critic
review that really has since painted it
as being you know where the worst
superhero films ever and really the fan
review as well that we're looking at was
Suicide Squad film hated it so maybe if
you weren't familiar with the comics at
a time and went in and were like Jared
Leto you know like maybe for those
people it was cool I mean I think a lot
of people also were excited to see
somebody's take on um Joker that's why
they started pushing Joker so much in
the marketing when he had he didn't
didn't even need him in that movie I'd
say that movie of the past like five
years or whatever is one of the ones
it's most responsive to the marketing
because when we saw those first
dark-themed trailers that were very
Batman versus Superman and everything
was kind of gritty everyone was talking
a lot of [ __ ] and that's also right when
they had the Joker reveal that you know
the damage to in that picture and
everything was looking so bad yeah and
they did that one trailer to Bohemian
Rhapsody and and they edited that way
and it cuts and then they did like the
neon paint yeah rebranding I've never
seen such a quick pivot but I've also
never seen that work so well that's why
I didn't that movie like just performed
so well suddenly people like wait this
looks really fun a lot of people are
gonna get shot up in a in the DC
Universe that's kind of an interesting
thing and then it still was the same
movie in fact they made it probably
worse yeah because they famously brought
in the editing team that did that last
trailer look you guys are so good can
you fix our movie yeah that never
happens you never have the the trailer
editing company take over the movie
itself they're in marketing they are not
in storytelling they're in a different
kind of storytelling I don't want to
like dismiss they do great work a lot of
these trailer houses do but like it's so
we're just a hand the movie over to them
to re-edit and I think that why it felt
like such a tonal mishmash when you're
watching it like what why am I suddenly
in a flashback 40 minutes in the movie -
who Deadshot's backstory is it felt like
it's confused but i think people love
them soundtrack that they sell that
money to put in that music is still on
the radio I love this track Hot Topic
sold a ton of guys like James Gunn's
version of the movie like I
why he feels like yeah I'm gonna tell
the version of Suicide Squad that should
have been the case in 2016 when that
came out it's just like it's just a
weird title unless like that's gonna be
a joke in the marketing of the movie
like like we're we're gonna call it
really this is the Suicide Squad actual
Suicide Squad yeah the last one was fake
squad yeah this what's also though we're
putting a lot of importance on the word
uh but yeah it could be what if like DC
just sticks with this right like the
Batman the Suicide Squad the Wonder
Woman movie or like they could do that a
Man of Steel what's the third one is it
a Suicide Squad no really the Suicide
Squad comic suicide worth noting by the
way it's isn't it the guardians of the
galaxy yeah there's a lot of words to
get through there yeah so yeah maybe it
is like going to be a full reboot but
also it just feels like a weird choice
using the definitive article I feel like
makes it very self-important yeah this
is the only one you need to care about
you know attention to that suicide there
works for the Ohio State University hey
that's what you said earlier and then
you stole now you guys feel this way too
I feel like The Wonder Woman sounds more
awkward than the Batman cuz people have
said the Batman Batman Wonder Woman well
to me the putting that article there
always is harkens to media right like
the coverage of the character so it's
like oh it's almost like that spider-man
figure out there whatever so the Wonder
Woman it switches the perspective from
her story to kind of like our perception
of her like oh we have that Wonder Woman
out there that's saving the day for us
can't we get her they should do what the
yellow pages do and it should be Triple
A Wonder Woman shows up first when
you're there's something like notorious
that comes with it too right like the
Batman the Spider Man or the Suicide
Squad like people are talking about them
and it almost kind of like in a negative
way and to hero kind of way you wouldn't
say the Wonder Woman because she's such
an inspirational figure she comes from
like
this that's other Island and she enters
our world in kind of the way Superman is
like I don't do people say the Superman
like I don't like the penguin is okay
but like people don't say that two-face
but if he was the penguin man we
probably would call him to think man yep
from now on because Nightwing
all right guys it's time for my favorite
part of show just as much as any other
part of the show I like it all the same
it's called Rove question so Disney
announced oh yeah by the way I don't
know these questions I'm reading them
for the first time and I'm not great at
reading we all right Disney announced
plans this week to remake some Fox
properties including home alone quick
pitches for how to update home alone for
2019 well obviously they have a simply
safe system which we did do a brandy
would simply say if a while back so
thank you doorbell Cam's yeah yeah break
in because they have simply I mean
they've already had the theory that saw
is Kevin McCallister becomes the that's
terrifying
III think it's all smart home hacking oh
that's good yeah like everything in the
house is controlled with like if this
than that and it's it's this kid that
just gets on the phone is that you mean
that if this end that kid like you're
like a coating that basically meant so
the kid is like super nerdy boys I think
I think I'm very nerdy but like if
you're like shutting a garage door on
somebody's head because you have a scar
garage kill him with the garage door
yeah sure all sorts of stuff but between
thermostat sprinklers garage door like
house but like just completely control
the house from like a safer a must is
there like a Disney Channel movie
this whole story could take place in the
cyber world the way like Tron or ready
player one like the battle is fought in
the machine and like they have avatars
and he's you know using pain can scar is
it like a truce what if it's just like a
sequel it's like later on like Kevin
McHale was all grown up it's just like
gritty like is this still living in the
house like he never moved out next door
now with the shovel oh yeah he had to
start doing it maybe the shovel man and
the bird lady from Danny Trejo saved a
child after a car wreck this week what
movie star would you most like to be
saved or rescued by hmm who ever played
like Wendy peppercorn in the sand would
make they would make the cut for a 20-19
person yes probably not but really
though I believe I'd like to be saved by
like Timothy Olyphant
it's like a reboot who needs like a
career reboot you know he fails and
saving you and then you both story is
the saving new part yes he seems you a
lot of money on your taxes yeah science
is really sweet about it after yeah
these were very obscure names by the way
I just
a Tennessee man whose real name is Luke
sky Walker of was arrested this week for
theft what's the funniest thing he could
have stolen regular colored milk our
power converters probably a fake hand
right
whatever those big see manatees ah notch
to like stolen a kiss from another
family member
see and I was gonna go with like a prop
replica of some sort like he likes chola
really expensive prop replica lightsaber
or like a bantha sleeping bag or you
know something like what if he stole
like a Star Trek phaser because he
doesn't really know Rogan Rogan who
produced Amazon's the boys tweeted out a
series of one-star reviews for the show
from graphic it all was boy yeah what
kind of negative review would make you
want to watch something more
how much profanity is in it it was too
compelling I was too interested I
couldn't look at my phone this world was
simply not real enough with all these
magic all the magic and Dragons in it
too many animals in this story today is
international cat day I hate these
questions every day on the Internet last
time we talked about mustard and we had
it I guess at least a cat is alive
what's your favorite pop culture cat he
danced in the cast
please also keep a tally of how often he
had the best theme song Garfield was
cool snagglepuss is great the cat that
Rachel Anna morphs into in an amorous
number three the Star Wars Galaxies edge
is getting its own cookbook based on
dishes served in the park so I'm gonna
list a dish and you tell me if it's
really served in the park okay okay all
right
mustafar Ian Lavar role real pay yes not
real balls real actually revealed it
before you Ithorian garden loaf fake
fake fake real loaf who was a garden low
Gungan spice hot wings
real fake fake i said fake for all of
them a taste of takodana I'm gonna say
real that sounds real real Mon Calamari
oh I mean it's too good it's just like
like eating bantha we're saying fake
fake fake are you saying fake I said
fake okay it's fake the curse is broken
scratch to provide a squid dish okay so
you're kind of cheating a little well I
don't remember everything they said
about you to the black spire this one
I'd say is my favorite name moof juice
don't come in a jar it would be milk
would net real I say it's real I'm gonna
say real - it's real is that real punch
milk because they do the blue milk yeah
yeah ammu fizz a very special part of
someone's okay anyway wookie waffles
with Java juice please yes yes fake
should be let's get on some let's make
that we'll make that together yeah
cookbook mm-hmm he's always end with a
fried Yoda with kylo Ren tears that's
definitely real take it up with the card
writer oh it stinks it's amid the end
yeah that's fake that's also this whole
upset of rotating
thank you so much let's go just real
quick where we can find you guys trisha
hershberger you can find me on all the
social zat that GRL trish so it's like
that girl trish but without an eye in
the word girl but it does have an eye
into where Trish yes just not an art
that GRL Trish kind like that girl Trish
if that makes any sense
I'm but you can find me on all the
social zaire or on YouTube or twitch
slash Trisha Hershberger or if you watch
caffeine dot TV new eggs YouTube channel
Kingston's YouTube channel or geek and
sundry's twitch channel in those places
as well
rats and Brandon just the corner of
ranting on my Twitter at grin and barek
hashtag Swiss cheese brains
grin and Barrett grinning Berry's but
you committed to it ten years ago okay
yeah so on the channel our good friend
marina master Oh sis back she's flying
solo to talk about the different ways
the MCU could reboot the Fantastic Four
some of the conversation we're having
here but she's gonna go into a couple
different interesting series for ways
the MC might have already set up this is
this crossover opportunity we have
another video coming out where the
in-game screenwriters talked about like
how Thor's storyline and if any an
infinity war almost derailed the whole
thing they felt like retool it and it
kind of sets up a possible villain for
Thor 11 Thunder so I kind of go into
some theory on that
and some other Marvel related stuff and
whenever Chris Nolan finally drops his
actual online YouTube version of Tennant
we have some theories on what the hell
that trailer could be if you saw Hobson
Shaw tenets trailer means nothing it
seems like the most mundane blase
trailer but if you look at like the
camera angles there's some weird like
head editing hiccups that like man if
you like cross your eyes the way I do
overall our trailer breakdown I think we
might have cracked the code for what
Tennant might actually be next time guys
I also follow him I'm Phil Malik find me
on Instagram and Twitter is thought
Malina do not forget to subscribe to the
rogue theory podcast feed this is all a
conversation that you're hearing in the
future for people that only see it on
the YouTube channel that makes sense to
like one person also follow us on
Twitter
just all around at new rock stars and
we'll tell you what we have going on
thank you guys so much grateful thank
you old friends
[Music]